اهلا بك يا محمد ما هو حاصل في هذه
اللحظات ان المواجهات التي كانت اندلعت في
مدينه بوردو جنوب غرب فرنسا من خلال اشعال
حرائق خلال المواجهات بين الشرطه
ومتظاهرين في عده احياء من هذه المدينه
هذا التوتر انتقل قبل دقائق من الان الى
باريس حيث سجلت مواجهات خلال التظاهره
المركزيه التي كلما تنطلقت من ساحه
الجمهوريه ساحه قبل حوالي
من الان وبدا الطلائعها تصل الى ساحه
لناسيون ساحه الامه المسيره بين الساحتين
تخللتها مواجهات خصوصا خلال الدقائق
الاخيره حيث سجل اشعال حرائق خلال هذه
المواجهات اما في مدينه مرسيليا فقد اعلن
عن مشاركه 180 الف متظاهر في التظاهرات في
هذه المدينه الشمسيه فيما تحدثت النقابات
عن 180 الفا قالت وزاره الداخليه ان
المتظاهرين لم يتجاوز عددهم الاحد عشر
الفا تحدثت النقابات ايضا عن 25
من المتظاهرين سجل ايضا نزول 25 الف
متظاهر الى مدينه الليل الى شوارعها وفيما
يتعلق اعلنت نقابه للعمل
المتظاهرين في العاصمه حتى الان وصل الى
450 الفا بالمقارنه مع 800 الف العدد الذي
كانت اعلنته النقبات يوم الخميس الماضي
طبعا نتحدث هنا عن الاعداد التي تعلنها
النقبات وبالنسبه للوضع القائم فيما يتعلق
بعناصر الشرطه والدرك قال وزير الداخليه
انه يمكنه اتهام اليسار بالحقد على عناصر
الشرطه داعيا الذين يعتدون على الشرطه الى
الاعتذار عن ذلك قبل قليل سجل ظهور اشخاص
مقنعين ويرتدون ثيابا سوداء ظهروا باعداد
قليله محمد ولفتره وجيزه خلال التظاهره
الفارسيه وهؤلاء ينتمون الى المجموعات
وهي مجموعات فوضويه لا تنتمي الى تنظيم
محدد وانما تؤيد اليسار المتطرف عموما
بالنسبه للمخارج النقابات دعت الحكومه الى
قبول وساطه بينها وبين السلطه التنفيذيه
بمعنى ان يتوسط طرف الماء بين النقابات
والحكومه لكن الحكومه سارت على لسان
الناطق اسمها اوليفيا الى القول انه لا
توجد حاجه لاي وساطه فالنقبات والحكومه
يمكنهما
انسى وجه ومباشره